hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar lessons from the laboratory
optimizing your tissue processing
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrutz and brought to you
by leica biosystems to learn more visit
leicabiosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits window at the bottom of the
screen to obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
robin pfitzel senior field application
specialist leica biosystems
robin you may now begin your
presentation
and thank you for that introduction
this webinar entitled tissue processing
artifacts
will discuss how to optimize your tissue
processing and recognize the cause of
common artifacts
the learning objectives for this webinar
are as follows
discuss pre-analytics and the impact of
improper fixation and artifacts on
tissue processing
discuss fixation and the impact of
incomplete fixation on tissue processing
we're going to describe the impact of
improper prosection
which is actually the dissection and
sampling of tissue
and determine satisfactory processing of
samples
last but not least we're going to
explain why routine maintenance is a
critical success factor to proper tissue
processing
this slide has two examples of what the
ideal sections in a perfect world would
look like under the microscope the skin
section on the left is clean with the
eosin staining the components of the
dermis with different shades
the colon section on the right is crisp
and well has well-defined nuclei you can
see some of the cells even contain mucin
there is no background staining or
muddiness to the stain this is a perfect
example
one artifact seen in the lab that is not
uncommon is crush artifact
you can see that the lung section on the
left is architecturally preserved while
the section on the right has mild
compression at the bottom center the
staining although i'm not ideal on the
right is okay
but you cannot see some of the alveolar
sacs like you can on the left
does the cause of this artifact could be
maybe compressing too hard with blunt
forceps one way to optimize
and to avoid this artifact is to
exhibit care when handling these type of
tissues
this is an example of mild artifact
a little bit more severe
uh situation in this sample would be as
you can see again on the left is an
architecturally
preserved section of lung
while on the right
is a section of lung that has moderate
crush artifact
in a severe example you can see again on
the left we have a well-preserved
section of lung while on the right
near the top
left corner
you can see that there is crush artifact
that actually has caused nuclear
streaming
an artifact that is commonly seen is
cauterization
you can see a normal section of breast
tissue on the left that shows connective
tissue evenly staining while on the
right
the section although it is lighter near
the top center is an area that is darker
if you were able to go down on higher
power the nuclear detail would either be
absent or unclear
cauterization oftentimes
cannot be controlled in histology as it
is a part of the surgical resection
procedure to remove the tissue but it is
good in this slide to at least recognize
it
an artifact common in the research world
are perfusion artifacts i know that this
is a technique
that's vital to whole organ fixation in
research
and for optimal results care must be
taken to avoid architectural damage to
the tissue
you can see here
that that the section on the left of
lung
shows the normal architecture where on
the right the spaces are more open more
wide that indicates there's been damage
by profusion
the next two slides will demonstrate the
results of little or no fixation and
result in degrees of autolysis
the section on the left is a beautiful
section of kidney here you can see the
glomerulus and bowman's capsule
they components that are easily
appreciated
in contrast the kidney section on the
right where the architecture is
preserved but the cellular details are
scanned
this would be considered mild autolysis
because there are areas where the nuclei
can be seen there's a little you can
still identify tubules but it's not as
nice as the section on the left
here we have a nice section of liver on
the left
you can see the hepatocytes with nuclei
that have well-defined nuclei and
sinusoids containing rbcs
while the section of liver on the right
is an example of severe autolysis
the architecture is not only skewed
but there is little or no cellular
detail
let's move on to another artifact that
deals with contamination
the next three slides will show examples
of such on this section of brain
you can see
by the red arrow that there is it's been
contaminated with plant material
on this slide the section of lung has
been contaminated with a section of
liver tissue
here we have a section of cardiac tissue
contaminated with a small fragment of
thyroid
to optimize all of these contaminant
scenarios shown here in the last three
slides
it is best to avoid
these types by keeping that a section
tools one uses and the space where the
dissection occurs clean
formalin pigment is another artifact
that occurs in the lab and it is when
formalin is not buffered
to optimize it is ideal
to either make up or purchase
formalin that is buffered at a ph of 7.2
this is a section of bone that has been
properly decalcified
here you can see the detailed structures
such as the compact bone
bone marrow trabeculae and the
periosteum
contrasting
to that section
is an under decalcified
section of bone that results in areas
that are thicker
and that stain darker
of course the opposite of under
decalcification is over decalcification
as again on the section on the left
is even and well stained and the
structures are easily identified
on the right you can see a section of
bone that has been over decalcified
over decalcification also and can
adversely affect your ihc such as kappa
and lambda that would not work with this
section
be aware that decalcification solutions
whether they're purchased or they're
formulated in the lab
are harsh usually acidic
so monitoring the process of the time
needed to get to the end point where you
can get a section is necessary uh but
being mindful of that time is important
so that you not only have
um good histology when it comes to h e
but that your ihc results are are good
too let's turn the tables and have it be
your turn
can you tell me what can cause these
type of artifacts
let's discuss the first one
in the histology lab when tissue is
submitted for processing
the cassettes are designed to hold
sections that are no more than 2.5 by 2
centimeters in length and in width
the thickness though should not exceed
more than three millimeters
here the section appears to have the
correct length and width but the cross
hatching of the section
indicates that the section was way too
thick
the second artifact i showed you
is due to sponges in the cassette that
are sometimes necessary for tissue that
is very small or tissue samples that are
mixed with blood
or mucinous material
but sponges too can also cause artifacts
that can be seen here
when we have appropriate fixation the
result is this beautiful section of
colon
you can see that it again is clear
there is no background staining
the ears no muddiness of the stain the
nuclei are well defined all the
structures here are clean and crisp
in order to get these type of sections
that turn out great as in the previous
slides shown
one key ingredient is fixation
the standard rule for fixation is
usually 20 parts of fixative to one part
tissue
not the reverse
as you can see with this image
that clearly gives you an example of
what not to do
let's talk about zonal fixation
so you may have
uh the right ratio of formalin to the
specimen but if you have hollow organs
or large
tissue resections you want to make sure
that the section the
hollow organ is open and that a large
specimen is prepped so that the fixation
can occur throughout the specimen
this is a side
view
through uterus
so you can see that the about the outer
half
has formula fixation but the endometrial
canal
also looks like there's a submucosal
fibroid there has a little bit too much
red pink appearance to it which
indicates to me that not only has
fixation not
reach this area but it also looks like
it might have some
beginnings of autolysis
when we look at it under the microscope
you can see here the section on the left
is
is it would be an example of a
good fixation this is decent staining
where on the right you can see there's
already some breakdown of that gland
so we know that shrinkage occurs at
every stage of processing um
but the harshest by far of course is
ethanol
here is the result of tissue not being
completely fixed by formula and then
being placed in alcohol
the sections on the left hand side are
examples of ideal liver and kidney
while on the right these sections
uh the fixation step has been completed
by alcohol
there is excessive
shrinkage and hardness of the tissue
which makes it more difficult to section
and usually on the microtome you might
see thick and thin sections where you
might end up on the slide with a thicker
sectioner than usual usually you're
cutting anywhere from three to five
microns and so the stain is going to be
heavier
also here and this is a whole other
subject but when you have over fixation
and over processing you have the
possible loss of course of bound water
this is an artifact of an example of
buffered salts this is an extreme
example of the salts making it all the
way through the processor
to the paraffin block but you can see by
the red arrows scattered actually this
is uh on the left-hand side is numerous
holes that indicate that buffered salts
are in the tissue this occurs when
neutral buffered formalin and usually
the following alcohol is above 72-73
percent there is an acid-base reaction
that causes the buffered salts to
precipitate out
going back to that beautiful section of
colon
shows here again that is clean and crisp
the nuclei are easily seen near the
basin cells
this is an idea of what we're looking at
with appropriate dehydration
when tissue is over dehydrated of course
shrinkage and loss of bound water can
occur
the sections are then more difficult to
cut and hydration with water is needed
these sections of bowel show chatter and
some areas of darker staining
take note that this section can
represent more
than one root cause
remember the section on the left is what
we're going for
it has crisp staining with well-defined
nuclei and cilia compared to the section
on the right that is an example of
severe over dehydration that not only
results in chatter and darker staining
as we discussed in the previous slide
but also you can see these artifactual
spaces
here is that great section of bowel
that is evenly stained and structures
well defined
contrasted to the one on the right
that has been under dehydrated
here you can see that the staining is
murky not well defined that is because
there is still free water present
note that this section can represent
more than one root cause
let's talk about appropriate clearing
remember this is the ideal section we
want the section is clean
crisp evenly stained
structures such as the nuclei are easily
identified near the base of the cells
when tissue is over cleared shrinkage
and loss of bound water can also occur
that is because if xylene is used
it has a dehydrating characteristic much
like alcohol
the sections again are then more
difficult to cut and hydration might be
needed
these sections of course show again
chatter and some areas that are staining
darker than they should
to
minimize or even
avoid over clearing take in
consideration
not only how many steps of clearing that
you have on your protocol but also if
there are temperatures on those steps
that might be contributing to over
clearing
remember again that the section on the
left is what we're going for
the section on the right is an example
of over clearing that has not only
resulted in chatter and dark staining
but also again those artifactual spaces
again if xylene is used it has that
dehydrating characteristic like alcohol
so the sections are more difficult to
cut they can show the chatter
and areas of dark staining so be mindful
of the steps of your clearing
again here is that wonderful section of
bowel on the left
compared to the section on the right
that has been under cleared
this section looks familiar right
you can see that the stating again is
murky not well defined and that is
because there is still
probably some water still present
remember i'm showing these some of these
sections in duplicate because you can
have the same appearance but different
root causes
let's talk about wax
infiltration remember again
this is what we're going for nice
section of bowel that is clear no
background staining and murkiness
everything is well defined
again here is that great section of
bowel just just to show you the contrast
of a section on the right that shows
incomplete wax infiltration
you can see the section is murky not
well defined
and looks familiar to previous slides
i've shown you
again
you can have this appearance on the
right but have several root causes
to avoid or to optimize
this to avoid this artifact
taking in consideration of the paraffin
infiltration times
might need to be considered
um
also two you always want to have vacuum
on your paraffin steps to pull out any
residual xylene that might be in the
tissue section
let's talk about maintenance
recollect that this is the ideal section
we want right
it's clean it's clear it's crisp we've
talked about some of the details
but i've saved the best for last because
this unfortunately is an area that's so
often dismissed
remember
optimal histology sections are what we
were targeting right
do these seem familiar yes
that is because if proper maintenance is
not performed residual water dehydrans
and clearance can cause this type of
poor histology seen on the right
even if you don't have enough paraffin
stations or vacuum on your paraffin that
leaves a little bit of residual xylene
in the tissue
this is the result of that too
as a final suggestion working with your
field application specialist and
performing regularly scheduled
preventive maintenance could optimize
these processes
leica has 14 specialists across the
united states and a technical support
center as well in the chicago area
thank you so much for your time and now
we will move on to questions
thank you robin for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
what is the best ratio of formalin to
tissue for optimal tissue processing
results
thank you for that question
first of all we want to be sure that
your formula is fresh and buffered at
around 7.2 ph
then if you have a hollow organ
such as a uterus
bladder
any any organ that is large also like
kidneys or liver i want to be a be sure
that you prep that specimen according to
your
facilities protocols so that the formula
can access every area of that specimen
to ensure proper fixation
all right thank you
next question
what are two examples of typical
laboratory processes that can impact
quality tissue processing
i can think of a couple i think the
first thing that comes to mind it is a
common practice that we see in the
laboratory
where
if the tissue cassette is three by two
and a half by zero point five
centimeters in dimensions which is
standard right
for some reason the
person
submitting tissue thinks that all of
that is there real estate and it's not
we need to leave at least a half a
centimeter
along the width and the length of the
specimen so that fluid can flow through
also two
we talked about in the presentation if a
specimen is over three or four
millimeters in thickness then you're
compressing the tissue down when you
shut the lid and and and then uh
restricting access of the fluids to
process the tissue
the other one i can think of i think is
that i think it's common in
the life science arena is to only have
maybe one or two protocols
and if you are sharing a core facility
uh you know different projects might
entail different species of uh to be
studied and with that i think comes the
consideration of
customizing your protocols
for example
i know that tissue that may be small
it's not going to require
an eight hour 12 hour run where
organs that are large especially like
fatty tissues are going to require much
more time so customizing those protocols
too i think those are two important
factors to consider
thank you
next question
what are a few possible causes of
reagent artifact resulting in poor
tissue processing
i think um
the number one thing that comes to mind
and i saved it to the last of my
presentation
and it's the most common thing that i
see in the field
is maintenance
changing the reagents checking the
reagents if you're making formalin up in
the laboratory checking the ph
i think it's all around the integrity of
those reagents that you're using
that's the number one
item the issue that i see in the field
and that i'm having
to talk to people about is
not only fresh reagents but having a
schedule there that is a regular
uh either depending on the volume of
tissue that you're processing determines
on how often you're going to change
reagents
right
next question
what is the single most important step
to ensure that optimal tissue processing
takes place within the chosen platform
every time
oh i think if i knew the answer to that
i would be retired
that's a great question i i think i can
speak to maybe a couple of things i
think it's a two-part
question uh
the first part is pre-analytics
pre-analytics
uh is such an important
uh
arena to really consider when you are
getting ready to process tissue
making sure that it's fixed making sure
you're not you know overfilling the
cassettes
simple
things to think about but so often
overlooked
i think with the second part too when
it's on the processor and you've done
your validations you have fresh reagents
i think again it's key
uh to the maintenance
thank you thank you for that question
next question how do you overcome zonal
fixation
again yeah any organ that's uh
considered large i i have to try to give
some type of reference so probably if
you're going to do tissue processing on
a
mouse or rat brain you definitely
probably going to use maybe a perfusion
technique i don't know i don't
originally come from the life science
background my my experience is only in
clinical uh but i've been with leica for
12 years so i've learned a lot in the
life science arena but
if you are not going to profuse then
definitely you want to buy valve or open
hollow organs at least pierce them and
make in and especially
uh even small specimens like lymph nodes
they have that kind of pseudo capsule on
the outside you want to pierce those so
that formula and fixation can get in
that tissue and and do all those
covalent bonding it needs to do
thank you
next question
how should i approach fixing chatter on
glass slides
oh i i i don't know that you can
the
architectural damage has been done
i am not aware
of being able to undo it
there are some things that we can do
when it comes to processing but it
usually deals with under processing not
over processing
all right thank you
next question what would be an effective
way to decalcify arteries
make sure that you have plenty of
fixation you know the standard fixation
time uh
in the research arena i know is usually
around 24 to 48 hours and all of the
research folks are great about moving
that tissue out of fixation into 70
percent but once it's you're confident
that it's fixed then you can either
place the tissue before processing
it depends on the degree of
calcification too
if it's just mild you can go ahead and
process the tissue and then once you cut
into the block when it's in paraffin you
can just do a face decal to try to get
that section but if it's a little severe
then you definitely want to do the
decalcification after you've done your
fixation be sure and rinse it
all right thank you
next question
are there artifacts specific to the
brain
i would have to think about that
this is one you can answer via email
i think that would be a great because
i'm not sure exactly um yeah i would
need to know a little bit more
information nothing comes to my mind off
the top okay
yeah off the top of my brain
all right
um
next question
would you please explain what perfusion
is
oh
uh from my understanding perfusion is a
technique where uh it it
uses tubing so for like lung you want to
move fixation through the specimen you
would place a tube that moves the tissue
it moves the fluid in and another tube
um usually they're using the
an artery and a vein to move fluid in
and move it out so it just kind of uh
uh
i'm trying to think of the best term uh
moves uh it perfuses right it's it's
accessing and maintaining the whole
organ without dissecting it yet
okay i think it's common in brain large
organs lung
like that yeah
all right
next question
would you use vacuum on your fixation
ethanol and xylene steps or just your
wax embedding steps
um
there's no
there's no codified method of how we do
our processing protocols uh
traditionally in when
at least as far back as the 80s i can
remember that we did pressure and vacuum
on every step because it was a necessary
uh catalyst for tissue processing
we always want to have vacuum on your
paraffin because you want to pull out
that little bit of xylene that's going
to be trying to stay in the tissue but
you can use i it's common to see
pressure and vacuum
on some processors
i have seen runs that don't have
anything on them until they get to
paraffin so it's it's about
what works for you and your laboratory
and your tissue uh every lab i have
found in the last 12 years with leica is
unique and does things a little bit
different in its
in the way they process and the way they
establish protocols but is it if it's
validated and it's working all the way
down even to your advanced staining
then that's great
great thank you
next question
uh
some why why would paraffin crumble when
cutting
due to humidity or because of the
embedding reason
probably i don't know that humidity
would be a factor but if it's crumbling
uh
sometimes it depends
i think we have to establish first is
the paraffin still
um the integrity still been maintained
uh if you want to make sure that it
doesn't get too hot
uh we want to make sure that it's um i
know that sometimes with maintenance
people tend to delay the time that the
schedule
of when they change it you can get an
oversaturation of paraffin but that
would be it would have a really soft
greasy feel to it with crumbling the
first thing that comes to my mind is
when you're sitting at the microtome and
you're using some type of freeze spray
to get it cold because we do have to
have it cool to get a section especially
if you're cutting you know down to two
microns it can be difficult in a warm
room
but if you're spraying it too much it
definitely will crumble uh sometimes
people will think they can put paraffin
in the freezer and certainly with a
minus 80 you don't want to do that
because it will crumble
okay
thank you
um next question what's the best
fixative for breast tissue
i think i can speak to what the standard
fixative is for breast tissue um
neutral buffered formula has as most of
you know has been around for a long time
and is the standard fixation i think
optimizing
that breast tissue for
studies that follow is what's really key
following if you're
especially in
a clinical setting it's different than
if you're in a life science arena but
that's if you
read any textbooks or literature i mean
24 to 48
is ideal um
and
that certainly is
different different requirements when
it's research versus clinical setting
all right thank you
next question
how long can processed tissue sit out
before it's embedded
oh
i love this question
uh because i think that
uh i've been a histologist for over 40
years and i think
we never really thought about
this type of uh question uh we didn't
for the most part tissue histology can
be pretty forgiving uh but we have found
with the introduction of molecular
testing and histology that we have to be
a little bit more aware of of what we're
doing in the laboratory and this is a
great question because it actually
addresses this
once it's processed and
i don't know this is my opinion or what
i've talked to other techs about and
their experience is that
the tissue once it's processed is
processed
so you if you feel like the embedding is
going to be delayed then there's not a
problem leaving it out i think the
critical component is ensuring that when
you are ready to embed your tissue you
want to be sure that it comes back uh up
to the temp of your embedding center so
it just can't be um the cassette just
can't be warm but you want to make sure
your tissues warm all the way through
right because if you embed it and the
tissue is slightly cooler then you may
not get the melding of the paraffin to
the tissue and then you can have trouble
sectioning
on the flip side of that
well well-processed tissue can be great
right it's ready for everything
downstream but i have
walked into laboratories where
cassettes that were processed
uh have been left on the embedder
for not only hours but i had a lab tell
me they left it in the embedder for
about a week
well the temperature is high and that
long-term exposure to that temperature
uh eventually
affected their ihc especially sensitive
markers like nuclear markers so that's a
great question love that question
interesting
all right next question
we are always getting understand
hematoxylin
in histopathology staining we are using
harris hematoxylin followed by bluing
and
i think that's supposed to be destaining
can any steps of tissue processing
result
result this problem
though eosin staining and tissue
morphology are fine
ah
this is a great question and one i would
definitely want to ask a few more
questions about
telling me that your eosin staining is
fine but not the front end of your
hematoxylin stain tells me it might be
an issue with your stain
line and not your tissue processing but
i would need to
look at a slide and
talk to
talk to you about you know the steps uh
some of the common problems with
hematoxylin staining is uh once you
clean it up with
you know usually we have a little
diluted acid rinse after water and then
we're going into the bluing uh but it
depends how fresh your hemotoxin is
right how much time you have on that and
if you are cleaning it up because it is
a regressive stain and you use a
diluted acid to kind of clean it up is
that too strong
right
so
but again you'd have to look at the
slide to be sure okay thank you
next question
how critical is it to utilize the warm
water water flush program on your tissue
processor if so how often should you be
using the flush program
ah good question
um
[Music]
this is uh
this is not
not present on all processors right but
there are some instruments out there
that do require water flush
uh the reason let me give a little
background on why we do warm water
flushes and it refers back to the slide
we talked about with formalin salts so
if uh through processing as formalin
moves from the formlin to that first
alcohol uh if it's a little too high i i
think i mentioned the 7273 it seems like
that's when it begins
you're going to have those buffered
salts coming out because of that
acid-base reaction
so that's why at the end
we actually do during our maintenance in
the clean cycle we do the warm water
flushes and that's to keep those salts
out of the instrument right
it's more to keep it number one out of
the tissue but also to keep the
instrument cleo clean of those salts
so i i know that at the end of a clean
cycle with some instrumentation it's
automatically there it usually goes
through a clearance a dehydrant and then
a water step
if you have those type of instruments
set up like that so it depends on how
often you're using the instrument
and it depends
on on your maintenance schedule
next question
uh
what do you exactly mean by chatter
oh sure um chatter is when the tissue is
of course
you know having difficulty on the
microtome and um it's it's it's dry for
one reason or another and another i
think term we use is venetian blinds if
that helps
so if you lowered your venetian blinds
and opened a little bit you can right
you have it's it's kind of a thick thin
step so you'll have a band that's darker
than a band that's lighter right above
it and it just follows repeatedly after
that and that's what we consider chatter
because the section is not even
it's not going to be that nice four to
five microns all the way across and
that's when you get the light and dark
staining alternating and that's what we
call chatter and that's usually over
processed
interesting thank you
you're welcome um next question
will over fixed specimens affect ihc
staining
yes
that is why we follow recommendations of
a maximum
uh time
uh it and i if you're doing ihc you're
going and you're doing formula fixation
usually you're going to do some type of
antigen retrieval
and that's what remedies the because
those covalent bonds
uh are so many when you have properly
fixed tissue where you want to be able
to expose those sites that you're
targeting for advanced staining
next question
can the crush artifact come from a tech
pressing down on a tissue too hard with
forceps during embedding
absolutely
yes care must be taken not only at right
at the board where they're prospecting
but all the way down
um
to the embedding
yes good great question
right
next question can paraffin expire and if
so
can it be used if it's expired
uh i do know that
when you purchase paraffin it does have
an expiration date
i would not
i don't you know profanes come in all
different type of flavors right
uh and it's all about the polymers that
they put in paraffin so if it was
expired i don't i think i would try not
to use i would not use that paraffin
i think long term it uh as you as you
move down and begin to use it not only
would it not process properly but at
sectioning i think it would make it
difficult also
all right thank you next question
how long must tissue remain in a
fixative and still be good for
processing
oh good question
i believe what uh i've seen in the
laboratory
of course it's different life science
versus clinical a lot of times we're
required in clinical to hold it for a
minimum amount of time where i'm not
sure in life science what what the
regulations are there but
when tissue is fixed uh like we've
talked about the 24 to 48 window when
you do your pre-analytical steps uh it's
moved in the life science rates usually
move what i've seen from formalin to a
70 alcohol which holds it for quite a
long time i don't know what the end
point would be to that
thank you
next question
how long
how long can tissue be kept in neutral
buffered formalin before tissue
processing for histopathology
i think that's a repeat of the last
question again too
um it depends if you're in the clinical
or life science arena
um there are restrictions here in the
united states
uh in regards to certain specimens about
formula and fixation but um i think if
as long as you're keeping that 24 to 48
hour window you're good
all right
thank you
and we will wrap up with that question
thank you robin do you have any final
comments for our audience i don't i
don't think uh
well i would like to thank everybody for
taking the time to be on uh certainly
reach out if you have any more questions
we'll certainly try to
get you some information that would help
your tissue processing
thank you again robin for your time
today in your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor like a leica biosystems
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time take care everyone and
goodbye